the president says a lot of people
should be ashamed of themselves clearly
many of his opponents or not chief White
House correspondent John Roberts has
that part of the story tonight from the
North Lawn can you jump
Frank good evening to you White House
officials say the decision to release
the memo was made by the president with
input from his national security team
including law enforcement and
intelligence officials and while the
White House praised the men and women of
the FBI and also pointed to what it
called bad actors with a political bias
against the president
meeting in the Oval Office with North
Korean defectors today President Trump
left no room for interpretation how he
felt about the memo I think it's
terrible you want another truth I think
it's a disgrace what's going on in this
country I think it's a disgrace a lot of
people should be ashamed of themselves
and much worse than that reaction to the
document came in like a flood Carter
page the Trump volunteer at the center
of the FISA memo said in a statement the
brave and assiduous oversight by
congressional leaders in discovering
this unprecedented abusive process
represents a giant historic leap in the
repair of America's democracy former FBI
director James Comey on the other hand
tweeted that's it dishonest and
misleading memo wrecked the house Intel
committee destroyed trust with
intelligence community damaged
relationship with FISA Court and
inexcusably exposed classified
investigation of an American citizen for
what
DOJ and FBI must keep doing their jobs
in a conference call Adam Schiff the
ranking member of the House Intelligence
Committee ripped the memo as blatant
partisan politics this wasn't about
oversight this is about telling a
political story that's helpful to the
president it's about telling a political
story that's designed to injure the work
of the special counsel and discredited
Speaker of the House Paul Ryan said it
was necessary to get the facts out in
the light of day the statements saying
that American Civil Liberties may have
been violated and that he has serious
concerns with the practice of using
political documents funded by a
candidate's political opponents to make
law enforcement and counterintelligence
decisions a big question raised by the
memo what happens to Deputy Attorney
General rod Rosenstein he oversees the
special
council investigation but the memo
reveals he signed one of the Pfizer
surveillance applications against Paige
in the Oval Office President Trump was
asked if he still has confidence in
Rosenstein amid accusations of a
partisan smear of the FBI the White
House said they would be happy to hear
opposing arguments the press secretary
is saying in a statement minority
members of the committee have reportedly
drafted a separate memorandum the
administration stands ready to work with
Congress to accommodate oversight
requests consistent with applicable
standards including the need to protect
intelligence sources and methods the
president's comments in the Oval Office
about Rosen Stein left some ambiguity as
to exactly where he stands so White
House officials were quick to clarify
that there has been no conversation and
no consideration about firing Rosenstein
Brett John Roberts live in the North
Lawn John thing